over the past few years Mexico's
president Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
has greatly expanded the role of the
country's Armed Forces
from building airports hospitals and
Railways to securing borders Mexico's
military has been handed control over
dozens of Public Works that were
previously managed by civilian agencies
never in the contemporary history of
Mexico has the military had access to
this amount of resources and civil
functions
most recently Mexico's armed forces were
assigned to monitor air traffic and even
given control of an airline
and now with violence and forced
disappearances in the country at record
highs Mexico's armed forces are taking a
leading role in policing the country
while many criticize growing
militarization in Mexico president Lopez
obrador insists that armed forces are
the only ones capable of curbing
violence
it's the same attitude Mexican
presidents have held since the start of
the so-called War on Drugs in 2006.
but human rights Advocates say the pace
of militarization under the current
government has grown exponentially
within a military state for a long time
I think we're entering a more dangerous
route which is militarism militarism is
the next phase it implies that is not
only security issues that are being
handed over to the military but that
they are being given political control
allowed to be fundamental actors in the
day-to-day government decisions and the
most dangerous thing is the political
participation they could eventually be
given
many Security Experts say that after a
decade and a half of boosting military
spending to curb violence in Mexico the
effect has been the opposite
arguing that more military has instead
led to more abuse citing deadly
incidents like the recent killing of
five unarmed civilians in Nuevo Laredo
at the hands of security forces on
February 26th
it's an assertion that President Lopez
obrador emphatically denies
idea
contrary to how things used to be there
are no human rights abuses the police
and military corporations do not torture
or Massacre nor do they forcibly
disappear people
president Lopez obrador is often
criticized for having an autocratic
streak his recent electoral reform is
seen by many as an attack on democratic
institutionality
but it's the president's affinity for
the military that's raising the most
concerns over the future Democratic
stability of the country
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico City
[Applause]